a la entrada de un pueblo dentro de
rusia a unos 10 km de la frontera con
ucrania
vemos un lanzacohetes múltiple apuntando
hacia ucrania
fuera
yury a 200 metros de distancia quiere
ignorar el hecho de que una guerra está
teniendo lugar para los cuales la
situación en este momento
todo es normal
pero hay muchos soldados no lo sé
[Aplausos]
sin embargo es difícil no notar los
convoyes blindados que se dirigen a la
frontera tanques misiles grad y la
misteriosa zeta de la insignia
en estas zonas a 15 km de la frontera
con ucrania la guerra tomó a la gente
por sorpresa justo después del anuncio
de vladimir putin de una inversión
extra para su amigo mi hermana me llamó
a las 5 30 de la mañana y me dijo putin
anunció que habrá una guerra con ucrania
y una hora más tarde todo ha comenzado
estábamos asustados muy asustados
estos residentes fueron despertados por
el sonido de los helicópteros y los
bombardeos
[Música]
nunca se les dijo que se estaba
preparando una ofensiva esta mujer
prefirió no dar su nombre estamos
esperando explicaciones que al menos
alguien nos advierta no tengan miedo
vamos a abrir fuego pero no nos han
dicho que es ninguna información no
sabemos nada de nada
vladimir putin desde 2014 y el inicio
del conflicto ha negado haber invadido
partes del este de ucrania y hasta el
último minuto antes de la invasión tenía
fuerzas en todas las fronteras
accesibles diciendo que estaban allí
para hacer ejercicios militares
[Música]